president Trump applauded for its new
1.2 billion dollar investment at three
Michigan plants he tweeted yesterday car
companies coming back to the u.s. jobs
jobs jobs exclamation point last night
on the CBS Evening News Jean Reynolds
reported that Ford's investment will
only bring about 130 new production jobs
the president's tweet was the latest
example of mr. Trump touting u.s. job
creation under his watch job supporing
back you saw what happened with Exxon
where they just announced a massive jobs
program
Charter Communications has just
committed to investing 25 billion
dollars and it's committed further to
hiring 20,000 American workers over the
next four years since my election Ford
Fiat Chrysler General Motors Sprint
Softbank Lockheed Intel Walmart and many
others have announced that they will
invest billions and billions of dollars
in the United States and will create
tens of thousands of new American jobs
Gerald sybiz Executive Washington
editor-in-chief commentator for The Wall
Street Journal and joins us from
Washington this morning Gerry good to
see you thank you
does the president deserve the credit he
appears to be taking for the jobs jobs
jobs well he deserves some credit but I
mean this is a classic case in in the
Trump world in which more credit is
being claimed that's probably do look
companies make no secret about the fact
that they think a deregulatory
environment which the Trump
administration is going to create and
the prospect of a big tax cut is
encouraging them to invest some more
money but the White House is taking
credit for jobs that were going to be
created anyway the Charter
Communications jobs were committed to in
2015 as part of a merger the four jobs
that the White House is taking credit
for were committed to by and large as
part of a 2015 deal with United Auto
Workers so what's happening right now is
I think that a lot of companies are
framing decisions they were going to
make anyway or had or had already made
as a response to the Trump
administration's arrival and the White
House is gobbling that up and taking
credit for it so there's some truth in
there but not as much as you're led to
believe Jerry there was a story in The
New York Times today about Blackrock
huge investment and managed
company that they are now going to use
robots rather than asset managers to
manage portfolios and that therefore
they were laying off some employees how
big of impact is technology gonna have
on job creation well you know I think
that's the bigger story within this
story you know there's been a lot of
debate about how much job loss there
comes comes from trade how much job loss
comes from unfair competition abroad but
the real job killer in America in a lot
of ways particularly manufacturing
automation you know robot comes into a
factory workers go away and that's
happening across the the manufacturing
sector and as that Black Rock story
indicates is now seeping into other
sectors as well and so I think that
automation is in its effect on
employment is probably the real story
here it just doesn't get as much
attention because the political debate
is much more about for example trade but
I think increasingly we're going to be
seeing questions about what a workers do
when automation is the problem not when
Mexico or China is the problem it's good
to hear the president talking up jobs
any president wants to do that and
Americans respond to that the question
is whether he can deliver on those
promises yesterday of course in
announcing rolling back some of those
energy regulations he talked about
bringing putting coal miners back to
work but there's a the the founder and
executive of Murray energy which is the
largest privately held coal miner in the
u.s. said that he told Trump directly I
suggested he temper his expectations he
can't bring them back yeah well I happen
to know some some lawmakers Republican
lawmakers from coal states are telling
him the same thing you know pull back
the the rhetoric a little bit because
you have to temper the promises you know
it is true that the the coal action will
give a reprieve to some coal-fired power
plants and I talked to some people down
in Southwest Virginia a couple of weeks
ago who said there are some people in
the cold industry being called back into
work now as a result of all this but the
long-term trends are still the long-term
trends natural gas supplies are going up
because of fracking the cost of
renewable energy sources is going down
as the technology improves and so
industry is moving on a long-term path
away from coal that's not going to stop
again there's going to be some
short-term beneficial impact in the coal
industry but not a change in this
long-term
and that's what the Whitehouse probably
needs to keep in mind as it engages in
this rhetoric about saving coal jobs you
know the president has been known to use
this Twitter account when he hears about
companies who are US companies who are
saying they're going to take jobs out of
the country do you think that affects
some decisions that companies are
planning to make or do make you know I
think it probably does I do think
executives sit in the c-suite now and
ask themselves do we want to be put in a
position in which we're attacked by the
White House for a decision that we might
make that's in the margins on the other
hand if we're gonna make a decision that
the White House likes do we not want to
get some credit for that that's a that's
a good thing for our for our company so
I do think it's probably affecting
decisions at least in the margins but
again you have to distinguish that from
long term trends and things that we're
going to happen anyway
all right Jerry Saad thank you always
good to have you here thanks a lot
appreciate it